ich konnte nichts machen nachdem du
nicht mehr verliebt hat es
für dich war für dich war zwischen uns
alles gesagt
so lange untätig war unfähig ich
brauchte neuanfang
dann habe ich fand's ist dagegen gewehrt
das hat mir selbstvertrauen gegeben
ich habe viel zu verdanken
ich muss mich bei dir entschuldigen ich
benehme mich wehren
ich finde du hast alles ziemlich gut im
griff ich meine die kann ich war einfach
überrumpelt dass deine freundin hast
also das duo ist
es gab mich damals auch ziemlich
überrascht mit dem heiratsantrag du
hättest dass sie sagen
ich habe es versucht aber irgendwie
was nicht geklappt tut mir leid
ich bestelle ich mir vor was passiert
wäre
wenn du mir ein antrag gemacht
also wären bald wieder eine tour
entstehen ich kann sich auf die gäste
des gesetzes gästeliste wäre schon cool
und was er mit einem backstage passt
also da muss ich jetzt mal die band
freilich nichts zu verlieren
ich bin unglaublich vielen dank
ich weiß dass hier soll mein bruder die
spaßbremse
wie langweilig wäre nur ein leben
eigentlich bin ich wegen dir wie geht's
dir dann scheinbar noch nicht so gut wie
ihr euch aber ich arbeite heißt was
heißt ich bin jetzt gleich wieder weg zu
überraschen
soviel zum thema beziehung ja ich muss
doch wirklich und ich bin gleich wieder
da zu hause
ich bin ganz zuversichtlich
ich wollte noch ein bisschen die seele
baumeln lassen
ja das würde ich jetzt auch gerne ich
sehe was gerade öfter als joe vielleicht
solltest du dir einfach mein tag frei
nehmen
die kampagne läuft nicht ohne mich
außerdem muss ich alte rechnung prüfen
von denen die hälfte keinen sinn ergibt
warum habt ihr da nicht eigentlich
jemanden für es gibt unstimmigkeiten und
noch können wir uns keinen eigenen
buchhalter leisten der die finanzen
kontrolliert kippen
ich werde ihnen unser zeigen bieten und
alles auf die
alex wird die vorläufige kalkulation
sehen probleme bei einem dermaßen großen
budget möchte ich die entscheidung nicht
alleine treffen
hast du mit den beiden technik
dienstleistern gute erfahrungen gemacht
ich lese gerade was von
veranstaltungstechnik müller und
edelweiß technik ich glaube da hat er
sich gefragt warum man mit zwei firmen
arbeitet das kann hier erklären
das hat ja auch gesagt ich will ja nicht
den tag vor dem abend loben aber ich
glaub es läuft super
wie wäre es wenn wir heute abend
zusammen essen gehen würden
ich muss noch mal los die jungs warten
scheinen wir müssen fit sein für die
tour
das passende outfit habe ich schon